une cérémonie d'ouverture le long de la
seine certaines compétitions d'un des
décors à couper le souffle en plus
d'être spectaculaire les organisateurs
de paris 2024 promettent des jeux qu'ils
respecteront l'environnement ils
profiteront à la population ces jeux on
les veut inclusif on les veut ouvert on
les veut on partage mais à l'ombre de
paris comme ici dans la banlieue de
saint denis certains projets dérange
c'est le cas de cette future bretelle
d'autoroute qui permettra de mieux
desservir le village olympique un projet
de 95 millions d'euros prévu depuis des
années que les budgets liés au giro
permis de financer nous sommes en droit
en tant que citoyen en tant qu'habitant
donc par an de dire non stop une fois
l'échangeur terminé les voitures
rouleront quotidiennement à quelques
mètres à peine de l'école maternelle et
primaire qui sera enclavé par des axes
routiers en plus d'enjeux liés à la
sécurité à melwood dire père de deux
élèves craint les impacts de cette
circulation dans un quartier déjà pollué
la loi olympique votée au parlement aux
france elle vous autorise à expulser ou
à exproprier juste pour accélérer des
projets mais vous a jamais autorisé à
asphyxier des gamins tout un quartier la
ville de saint denis n'a pas répondu à
notre demande d'entrevue les autorités
assurent que l'école sera séparée de
l'infrastructure par un écran de verdure
et que l'échangeur permettra d'apaiser
la circulation sur d'autres axes
routiers de la municipalité il n'y a pas
qu'à saint-denis qu'un projet lié aux
jeux olympiques de 2024 fait l'objet de
contestations ici dans la ville voisine
d'aubervilliers un groupe de citoyens
s'opposent à la construction d'une
infrastructure sportive la piscine
d'entraînement et déjà à l'état de
chantier le problème c'est qu'elle
amputera des milliers de mètres carrés
des jardins ouvriers un espace
communautaire qui existe depuis une
centaine d'années de leur s mijatovic
qui possède une parcelle de jardin fait
partie d'un groupe de citoyens qui
milite pour faire cesser les travaux
certains se sont même récemment enchaîné
à l'équipement de construction pour
empêcher le béton coulé où on est tous
enfin d'ici l'été quand il fait chaud on
étouffe l'été donc on a besoin d'
espaces dont détenir n'a pas besoin de
plus de béton qui fera plus de chaleur
qui fera plus d'air irrespirable un
tribunal a récemment demandé aux
autorités de revoir leurs plans en
raison de l'impact du projet sur la
biodiversité pour l'instant la
construction se poursuit la terne la
surface des jardins prise là par la
piscine sera reconstituée sur un ancien
terrain de football la mairesse
d'aubervilliers nous accorder une
entrevue avant que la justice se
prononce sur la question karine franck
les défend ce projet que son
prédécesseur à négocier elle assure que
les immenses budget lié aux jo
profiteront à sa communauté on a
absolument besoin d'infrastructures
sportives et notamment de piscine parce
que mes en seine saint denis à l'entrée
en 6ème donc quand les enfants de 12 ans
c'est seulement un sur deux qui ne
savent pas nager donc oui les jeux
olympiques sont l'opportunité de pouvoir
avoir des équipes un paysage transformé
mais aussi une crainte d'une
gentrification du quartier s'ils de leur
s mijatovic ne se pose pas au jeu elle
craint leur impact dans les banlieues
j'ai envie de dire ça s'appelle gio
paris 2024 ici on n'est pas à paris on
fait ici c'est la seine saint denis ça
s'appelle pas léger eaux de la seine
saint denis en fait cjo paris et ça
vient détruire ici les organisateurs et
les autorités publiques ont un peu plus
de deux ans pour convaincre les
sceptiques que le région ne sortira pas
perdante de ces compétitions ici rafale
biblio claire radio-canada à
aubervilliers